i'm obsessed with you host and i think
you're also involved in the production
you're an executive of f-boy island yeah
and i know that sona will never speak to
me again if i don't bring up f-boy
island oh god i love f-boys and we know
that's short we know it's we know it's
short for is it fine boy island it's
[ __ ] boy what yeah
that was fine boy well that's what my
mother told me she's a big fan they're
really fine boys
some of them are i say it's short for um
fragile boy oh very nice because that's
what that's what the where comes from
nice yeah so so fearful how involved are
you in
choosing because it's how many how many
women so it's three women who are
looking for relationships looking for
love and then there are um well we lost
a couple this year they're supposed to
be 15 and 15 points to a terrible
disease
we lost them to fire it is really hard
to contain a point got to tell you when
they're in cabo
and you know the pas that we're hiring
to
make sure that they don't get out and
get out into the community i mean they
got out and so we lost
wait so wait a minute
how many
let's make clear about this but how many
boys is it it's fifteen it was she's
been fifteen so it's 30 boys 15 are nice
guys that that means that you know they
they say they're nice guys there's no
way to really check but we they've cast
themselves as nice yeah and they you
know we do that we do check and make
sure that they're like they're mama's
boys they've been in good relationships
their ex-girlfriends don't have bad
things to say about them they're looking
for a relationship and then there are
guys that are there for the the
followers the clout the money prize at
the end if you get to the end and
convince this girl
that despite being an f-boy you are
actually ready for a commitment you have
a chance at a cash prize and then um how
many escaped there were like two three
two or three that means
that they really did escape it'd be
great if you were driving and you just
saw one run across the highway naked no
really
we'll let you tell the story so i would
really like i was would be driving
around cabo and i would just go is that
garrett what is gary doing out there
but then but now on the show it's third
we had to try to do you know change the
voiceover to their 13 f boys and 13 nice
guys but there were there were two two
more of each so they've just
they literally like went out and partied
and got
hookers or so you know like these guys
really party i mean they're used to like
they're used to having
multiple women a nightmare love you just
basically said you call him in on the
carpet and go excuse me when we hired
you [ __ ] boy
we didn't intend for you to be out
[ __ ]
now you signed here a document that says
i promise to be a good fuckboy
and you are out
of [ __ ] and sucking
you don't really have a legal leg you
don't have a legal latest when we
brought you to cabo to [ __ ]
we didn't think you'd go into cabo and
[ __ ] if anything they have a legal case
against you you put them up at like you
know a holiday in express next to sammy
hager's cabo wabo
it was calling to them i mean it was we
tried to like put them a little bit more
off campus but they kept breaking off
campus and getting out stay in the
library
finish your thesis that's a huge part of
these shows is keeping these keeping
these reality stars contained wow
you know what i love i just it's so
funny to me that you've got basically 15
testosterone i'm sure good-looking hot
uh
f-boys they get loose they get loose now
what if they blend with the population
and they have to introduce another type
of like [ __ ] girl to try to take down
the [ __ ] boy how they do snakes in the
amazon and things like that
like the natural ecosystem you are
putting way too much thought into it
this is why i'm not a [ __ ] boy this is
uh there's another reason
is it one that i don't know
well you smoke a pipe a corn cob pipe
affectations like that um so i'm curious
yeah do you think there really are
people that are looking for a real
relationship no
exactly right well here's the thing this
is what i do believe about these shows
and i i begged for this hosting job like
i i wanted it so bad because i've always
watched these shows enjoyed them more
than any other show
and i really fall for it like i drew i
do believe these people fall in love and
there's always a part of me that goes
are they really but they they really are
like these shows when you're put into a
bubble where you have no you have no
cell phone you have no family or friends
to talk to all you're doing is going on
dates and all you're doing is talking to
the other guys or the other girls that
you're with about the guys and the girls
that you're interacting with and every
interview you do with a producer is like
so ryan really likes you how are you
feeling about him like i saw you light
up when you talked like
you you quickly fall in love and it is
not fake like it's it really is a
pressure cooker for
uh
deep love i mean i see these people
fall really really hard and it's real
and i feel it and i get chills during
elimination ceremonies i tear up and i i
know it's called f-boy island i know how
stupid this is i saw the casting tapes
like but it really these people leave
the island devastated or in love it's
like it really does happen it's like a
experiment in a way and it's like a zoo
it's like
when people say that reality shows are
fake it bothers me because the scenarios
are fake but the emotions these people
are not that good of actors it would be
impossible the emotions are real we're
just no one watches two pandas mate and
is like that's so fake you know and as
do it's like no well we put them there
and they're gonna mate eventually when
the female panda has an orgasm i'm like
no
[Laughter]
trust me you know panda's really having
an audience
[Music]
[Laughter]
so uh
would you and i i know that you're a
producer on this and a host and so you
have clout would you consider at all
letting me be one of the hold on let me
say it it's f boys and conan so everyone
no it's me i'm not playing anyone else
but it's me as me i talk to my wife who
will happily give me a hall pass she
wants me out of the house yes and i'm
there but i'm myself yes i'm totally
myself you would kill you i mean you
they would love you no they wouldn't
they honestly conan they were yes they
were i have no when i take my shirt off
there's no there's no six-pack
there's nothing like that it would be a
jarring juxtaposition to the men that we
have
i'm not gonna deny you
but you're so tall that is so nice and
you're so famous you have a great head
of hair you have a nice body of you
would do fine and first of all you're
famous these guys we have so on season
two we have one person or a couple
people for that you recognize from
season one and these girls when they see
a guy from season one i mean it is like
brad pitt they you have such an
advantage for being a little bit known
so you'd kill but i would do a lot of
what i would funny i would just say and
i'm conan o'brien and i wouldn't even
after that i would just
totally name drop i wouldn't i would try
and just ride the fact that they knew
who i was if they knew who i was like
they would
can you [ __ ] yeah yeah
well that's an issue
you don't have that's gonna be a problem
that's gonna be a problem yeah and not
just because i'm i'm married and i love
my wife right there's another issue okay
it's a surgical problem
but there's a doctor in prague who says
he can fix it i bet there's one in cabo
too
you can get it in cabo isn't really a
licensed doctor
i've seen the work it's fantastic it
would be so fun on the show oh my god
it does crack me up the idea of going
down the long line of guys and then me
yeah and i have no shirt on and i'm my
age with my coloring and uh i'm
i'm just playing it totally like myself
the funny guys kill are you
are you shirtless or do you have like
your long uv protection shirt on your
bucket i think i think i would have the
stuff i wear at the beach that i've
always said makes me look like rose
kennedy
and i'd have the zinc oxide on the nose
yeah yeah and uh the giant crazy
sunglasses and block out
sidelight
so i've got that and then some kind of
weird orthopedic shoe
that's been built that's also been built
for the sand you know for for arch
support
but i'm there but then the whole time
and i'm constantly talking about the
things that interest me
like you know like on a date yeah i'd be
talking about like these weird
historical facts and i've been talking
about things that i find interesting
like the robert carroll books on lyndon
johnson and then every now and then i
just turn to camera and say but i'm down
to [ __ ]
[Laughter]
welcome to [ __ ] boy manor is there much
[ __ ] around here
not really
we discourage that i want you
on the next season i want you at an
elimination ceremony i want to call you
down
conan
um so you had a date with mia this
weekend
yes
um mia seems
did you have fun mia
she did she had a great time with you
ziplining um
how did it go for you conan how are you
feeling about mia right i tore my
rotator
cuff my body weight when i had to hang
from the zip line this is what we were
really gonna i couldn't um it totally i
could hear a tear
uh because i can't support my own body
weight and then but thank god mia um she
managed to get me to the infirmary right
away you guys seem to have a connection
my fireman carried him yeah
thank you mia you're welcome when you
firemen carried me to the emergency room
has reasons to doubt you though that
your intentions with mia might not be
completely true are you here as an f-boy
yes i'm not sure i understand
i i don't you say no you got to say no
but i want them to know that i i can f
if called to f
sounds like a true last year i can't
even say it
let me make it quite plain that though
not an f-boy in intent if call to f oh i
shall ask repeatedly
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
why are you wearing a 1920s straw boater
hat